how's it going Jas cough my name is Sam
Agnew and a company called Twilio pays
me to build goofy hats and speak about
them so and I flew in from New York City
the other day and speaking of JavaScript
developers from New York I just want to
give a quick shout out to my buddy
Daniel Kusano speaking at the other
track right now he's talking about how
the history of time and how time is a
social construct stuff like that seems
real cool you should watch it on YouTube
later because he also organizes a
meet-up called Queens j/s which is one
of my favorite ones and sometimes I
convinced my employer to give them money
anyway as you can probably tell by my
screen this talk is going to be more of
a fun one than a serious one it's the
last session before the closing keynote
and I know at the at towards the end of
conferences attention spans start to
wane so I figured what could be more fun
than just playing pokemon together in a
room full of JavaScript developers so as
you see on my screen I have a gameboy
advance emulator running pokemon red
version which is a game I played a ton
as a kid and what we're gonna do is I
have the windows version of this
emulator running even though I'm on a
Mac and the reason for that is there are
a lot of old game emulators where the
windows versions of them have developer
tools because people still make real
games for these old systems and for some
reason or other most of those developers
use Windows so one of the features that
this emulator has that I'm going to be
using for my talk is Lua scripting
functionality so we can write Lua
scripts that execute in the environment
of the emulator and we can control the
memory of the game and button input and
stuff like that I'm being miked up cool
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
write a Lua script that interacts with a
nodejs
Express server sitting behind a Twilio
phone number and
I'm gonna have all of you text a Twilio
phone number to tell tell me what
buttons to press in the game and then
the the node app and the Lua script are
gonna communicate with each other and
testing testing testing can you hear me
sweet awesome so this might sound kind
of familiar to some of you if you were
paying attention to the internet like
about five and a half years ago there
was a sting called twitch plays Pokemon
where there was a twitch.tv livestream
of the game pokemon red but instead of a
human being playing it was everyone
watching the stream typing in the chat
which buttons would be pressed and when
you have 80,000 people playing the same
game controlling it at the same time
things get pretty interesting so when I
found out that these emulators had Lua
scripting functionality which he could
use to control the game programmatically
the first thing I thought was I guess
because I work for Twilio I was just
like whoa wouldn't it be cool if you
could do that with text messages too so
I looked up all these api's and stuff
turns out these Lua scripting thing is
really popular in the tool-assisted
speedrun community where people try to
write scripts the the complete games in
the most efficient way possible this is
this is like a page about the Lua
scripting for the visual boy advance
emulator this documentation seems pretty
bare-bones
so I've actually been following this
other emulators documentation the fceux
emulator for nintendo games for
old-school NES games turns out they all
all these old game console emulators
they have the exact same Lua API
I guess because they're all open-source
and once one of them implemented it the
other ones were probably just like cool
gonna copy and paste that so here's the
fceux documentation you could do stuff
like read and write bytes to the games
memory in real time like the RAM and the
ROM and all that stuff we're not going
to get into that right now what I'm
gonna be using is the joypad library
which allows you to manipulate button
presses and stuff like that and what
we're gonna do is I'm going to have this
Twilio phone number set up so that I can
programmatically control it so whenever
you send
text message to this phone number and
it's a seven six zero number which I
think is an area code around here so
cool whenever you send a text message to
that number Twilio is gonna send a post
request to this URL right here Saginaw
and rokkyo / SMS which is basically a
tunnel to a port on my local machine
that my node Express app is gonna be
listening on that app does not exist yet
so we'll get to that later if you if you
text this number right now literally
nothing will happen because that it's
just being dropped on the floor because
the code doesn't exist to handle the
message yet but you will be texting this
number later I'll show it on the screen
later so you don't have to copy it down
right now anyway let's get into let's
get into the basics of how to write code
for this Gameboy emulator so I'm gonna
create a file called Pokemon Lua and I'm
gonna do a hello world thing you might
have seen in this uh on this right now I
have I have my Twitter handle up on the
Gameboy emulator my twitter handle is
Sagna shreds agnew as in Sam Agnew
shreds as in shreds on a guitar and
that's just like a quick hello world
script that writes my Twitter handle
let me show you how to do this you're
gonna call the EMU object EMU as in like
emulator not the animal that defeated
the Australian Army in a war one time
I've read that on Wikipedia so anyway
I'm gonna say hello je s cough with an
exclamation point and a smiley face cuz
I'm super happy to be here and I'm super
happy that you are all here and I'm
gonna save that and then in my a my I'm
gonna stop this other script from
running so my Twitter handles gonna go
away cool and then I'm going to go find
this Lua script on my computer in my
talks folder in the Jas conf folder
Pokemon Lua I'm gonna run that and it
says hello J s cough cool we wrote some
Lua
but it disappeared so the reason for
that is it's only running once it's just
printing once at one time but what we
can do is we can repeatedly print this
on every frame if we wanted to stay like
I just did with my Twitter handle and
for that we need to write an infinite
loop because infinite loops rule right
we write those all the time
so because this emulator the whole like
environment in there is single-threaded
this will actually stop the game from
even playing so this mu object gives you
a function where you can control the
frames so you can advance to the next
frame this way our infinite loop is
pretty much taking over the runtime of
the game so that each iteration of this
loop is going to be one frame of the
game so all this code will execute
execute on each frame so I'm going to
advance to the next frame at the end of
each loop I'm gonna restart that and now
the hello J s cough is going to stay
there so that's gonna be part of the
basics and what we're doing now I'm
gonna actually write some useful stuff
so what we want to do is this Lua script
is just gonna communicate with our node
J s stuff I know this is J s confident
writing Lua I'm not much of a Lua
developer I don't know how many of you
and you're in this room consider
yourselves Lua developers but I'm not
particularly so I'm just gonna write
some code to communicate with that node
J s and we're gonna do something
extremely technologically advanced here
really complicated stuff we're gonna
communicate by reading and writing to
text files yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna
read on each frame I'm gonna read from a
file called button dot txt to see if a
button was pressed and I'm gonna write
some utility functions for that real
quick so I'm gonna write a function that
can read a file and then I'm going to
open that file if I can type correctly
cool so I'm going to open that file name
with the read flag and then I'm gonna
check to see if that file actually
exists so if it's nil then I'm going to
set the input to be that file and then
I'm going to create a variable called
content and read the contents of that
file into it and then I'm gonna close
the file cuz you always got to close
something you open you got to finish
what you started right and then I'm
gonna return the content of the file
which should just be a string of
whatever was in the file and next I'm
gonna write a quick function to press a
button in the game so
this is gonna take a button just like
the text of a button like a bee start
select up down something like that and
the way the joypad API works and this
Lua scripting is that it takes a table
of buttons like a key-value kind of
thing like a JavaScript object or a
Python dictionary and it takes the
button name and true or false from
whether that button is a is being
pressed or not so I'm just gonna create
an input table here an empty one and I'm
gonna set whatever button we're trying
to press equal to true and then I'm
gonna call the joypad dot set function
and this is this is actually kind of
interesting right here it's like one of
the idiosyncrasies of this visual boy
advance Lua scripting is that I have to
give it I have to tell it which
controller to press this button on the
game boy is one player it's like
literally just the game boy right
there's no two controllers but I guess
because they copy and pasted the Lua API
from the other emulators for the
consoles you still have to give it the
button input so I guess unless you're
using a link cable there's only one
player but player one is gonna have this
input table and now I'm actually going
to go down to this infinite loop and
we're gonna say for each frame of the
game I'm gonna check to see if if there
is anything in button dot txt so I'm
gonna create a variable that is just
gonna read the contents of button dot
txt and I'm gonna delete this message
right there and I'm gonna say if the
button is actually a thing if it's not
nil then I'm gonna press the button
pretty simple right and then I'm gonna
put a message out saying I'm pressing
the button simply say pressing button as
I said I'm not much of a Lua developer
so blue a string concatenation is just
two dots so if that looked a little
funky to you that's what that is it's
just string concatenation and then I'm
gonna remove that text file so I'm gonna
delete button dot txt so that I avoid
duplicates like pressed like if you send
a to the text message thing and then it
writes the button to that file
I just want to press the button once I
don't want to like keep pressing
on each frame repeatedly because like if
you if you want to press the button
twice you'll just send a twice so and if
there is no button dot txt it's just
gonna return nil and then button is
gonna be nil so this won't get executed
but speaking of pressing buttons for
multiple frames that's another thing I
want to address so you are all human
beings and when you're playing a video
game
you're not playing as fast as a machine
would so when you press a button on a
gameboy or any controller really even if
you're trying to press it really quickly
you're at least holding the button down
for a solid portion of a second so we're
gonna want to press it for more than one
frame at least like let's say five
random number I'm gonna write a for loop
to basically just hold this button down
for five frames which is still not a
long time but long enough for it to
actually register and this is just the
syntax for a for loop in Lua
but I want to make sure I advance the
frame again after each iteration of that
loop and I think that's all the code I
need to write in Lua so we're done with
the part of the language we're done with
the part of the talk where I'm using a
language no one writes or probably some
of you do I guess I do because I'm
technically writing it right now I'm
going to open a file called button dot
txt but first I'm gonna reload this this
pokemon dot Lua script the Hello Jas
comp should go away cool now I'm just
gonna write the letter a capital letter
a in this text file and if I didn't mess
anything up when I go back to the
emulator it should be pressing the a
button and as you see it's like it's on
this menu screen so if it works this
should go to the screen where I select a
new game pressing a well I mean I guess
it said it was pressing a oh there we go
maybe five frames wasn't enough actually
but we'll see cool so the code works the
Lua code works that's good I'm glad to
hear that now I'm going to open up a
save state that I have because later on
once we're actually playing this I don't
want us to have to like sit through
professor oak telling us all what to do
and like you know I can I can play the
Super Nintendo saggin II was playing
this Ness pretty accurate statement
I still have my old Super Nintendo
hooked up in my apartment in New York
all right time to go now I'm gonna write
some JavaScript finally so I'm going to
open a file called index J s and I'm
gonna just build a quick Express app so
for a lot of people here who are already
familiar with with like back-end know
development this will seem pretty
straightforward to you for those of you
who aren't familiar with back-end nodejs
development I guess this will be a like
a little little Kickstarter a little
quick start on building a quick
server-side web app so first I'm gonna
import all the stuff I need gonna
require the FS module because you know
writing to files got to use the file
system for that also going to require
Express because it is the web framework
that I'm using and I'm gonna grab body
parser because I'm going to need to deal
with the body of a post request because
when you send the text message Twilio
sends the post requests representing the
message and I need to get stuff in the
body of that post request to access what
the text of that message is so body -
parser and now I need to use the Twilio
API the Twilio node module and I'm gonna
grab the messaging response object from
that so this will generate the twimble
for me twibell being Twilio set of XML
tags that tell us what to do with the
call or the text message so when you do
send a text message it'll send that HTTP
request and then my web apps gonna have
to respond with with these XML tags
particularly the messaging response 1
saying hey respond to this text message
with a message and no one wants to write
XML by hand I don't and I'm not going to
so I'm gonna do this cool now I'm going
to create my app object and I'm going to
make an array of valid Gameboy buttons
that you can text so these are going to
be the buttons I'm checking ants if you
text me something that's not one of
these then I'm not gonna input it in the
game so you could do up up down left
right a and B there are also the start
and select buttons on the game boy but
I'm not really going to use those for
this one because that opens up the
opportunity for you all to troll me by
spamming the Start menu and
that's not as fun so I'm just gonna not
let you do that at all
next I want to actually make sure I'm
using the body parser middleware can't
forget that so when I get the URL
encoded post body I'll actually be able
to use it I'm gonna write that real
quick cool now we can get to the the fun
stuff writing the post handler
so this'll this will be a / SMS route as
you saw me configure in my in my Twilio
console and I'm gonna write the callback
function that's going to handle that
request first thing I'm gonna do here is
I'm going to create a new twill
messaging response object so I can
generate that XML and then I'm gonna
grab the button that you want me to
press so I'm just gonna assume whatever
text message you sent me is only gonna
be a gameboy button and I'm gonna grab
that from the request body this is gonna
look slightly confusing because the
inside of the body of the post requests
the the value that I want is body with
an uppercase B because that's what
Twilio sends you as the actual text of
the message it's called message body so
I'm grabbing the body and I'm gonna
convert it to lowercase so I can make
this case insensitive and also so I
don't have to put the burden on you to
deal with your autocorrect and stuff
because if you try sending me left as
you see up here this is lower case and
you're gonna have like a capital L and
stuff we don't want to deal with that so
it's gonna convert that to lowercase and
then I'm going to see if what you texted
me is actually in our list of valid
buttons that we want you to be able to
text so if you text me start not gonna
get that so if you set me a valve button
I'm gonna add a message to this twill
object and this will be the text message
that I'm sending back to you in response
and I'm gonna say thanks for playing
pokemon with me and if you have any
questions i'm gonna give you my twitter
handle again at saggy shreds
so that's sag new as in Sam Agni shreds
as in shreds on a guitar or my email
address in case you want to send me some
more longer-form complaints about how
I'm using semicolons and you hate that
or something I'm going to send you a
smiley face back because I'm really
happy that you're all here
so next I'm gonna actually write this
button to the text file to communicate
with my Lua script but an interesting
thing here is there's another one of
those things about that Lua scripting
API is that when you're trying to press
the a or B button it expects it to be
uppercase but if you're trying to press
like up-down left-right starter select
it expects it to all be lowercase so
slightly annoying but we can deal with
that I'm just gonna quickly say that if
you're trying to press a or b I'm gonna
throw that back to uppercase oh no I
would actually want to say if you're
pressing a or B in this little if block
here then I'm gonna set the button equal
to uppercase button dot uppercase button
got to uppercase you know what I mean
cool so then I'm and I actually press
the button by doing this super complex
writing to a text file so it's gonna go
to button dot txt I'm gonna write that
button to it and I'm gonna go utf-8
encoding and now if you text me
something that's not a valid Gameboy
button I'm just gonna respond with a
message asking you to send me a valid
Gameboy button because you know you
might make a typo or something and I
don't want to send that to the Lua API
or maybe you just want to comment on my
hair or something I'm gonna just say hey
please text me a valid Gameboy button no
smiley face on that one
and now I'm gonna deal with actually
responding to this HTTP request so I'm
gonna make sure that it's a 200 response
because if I'm actually getting the text
message and stuff just gonna give it 200
let's go with that I'm gonna set the
content type to be text slash XML and
I'm just gonna send the twimble
object a string of five version of it so
this is just gonna be the XML that it
generates which is just gonna be the
text message that I want to send back
should be almost done now I just got to
make sure this app is listening gonna go
port 3,000 you know the classic classic
point 3000 I'm gonna console dot log
Express app listening on port 3000 I'm
gonna put a bunch of exclamation points
cool so before I that should be all the
JavaScript I have to write before I open
this up for you to all play pokemon with
me though I'm gonna make sure I don't
have any errors so I'm gonna run this
and I'm gonna text this if you did take
that number down then I guess you can
play it but I'm gonna text right I'm
gonna try to go right yeah someone
pressed up someone went left okay so
people are actually it looks like the
code is working at this point because
I'm not getting any errors and you know
what that means it means we get to play
Pokemon together so who wants to who
wants to play Pokemon until I run out of
time so I'm gonna need you all to take
your phones out and send a text message
to this number preferably a Gameboy
button seven six zero four nine two six
six five nine so that's seven six zero
four nine two six six five nine and
let's see if we can go select a starter
Pokemon and then battle our rival if we
can get past that I'll be pretty stoked
so yeah let's play some Pokemon so we
want to go right and down I want to get
out of our mom's house because we're a
big kid now we were going off on our
adventure what was Ash was like ten
years old in the
anime so we're ten years old ready for
adult life hey it's sag news house it's
my house
all right we got to go up we want to go
up and to the right yeah all right now
we want to go right let's do that isn't
it great that I didn't let anyone press
start because we would just be standing
still right now all right we want to go
up gotta get in the grass we gotta get
in the tall grass so professor oak will
see us and be like whoa it's a
ten-year-old kid going into the grass
where all these like vicious animals are
we need to you got to have your own
vicious animal buddy you got to be able
to protect yourself with like a squirrel
or something all right so you want to go
right and up let's do it let's do it
right I believe in you I believe that
this community can stick together and we
can we can defeat yes all right all
right oh yeah Oaks looking looking out
for us oh it's got our back now let's
just spam a and B so we can get past
this guy talking to us this is science
guy professor Oak the science guy cool
we're on our way
into his lab gonna get our first Pokemon
I'm excited I'm excited for our
adventure yeah we don't even have to
walk up the game scripts that for you as
you can see I named my rival fool
because it's it's it's customary to name
your rival something not nice and I
think he's kind of a fool so that's what
I named him when I was young I was a
serious pokemon trainer
cool you got three Padma I'm gonna spend
B so that we don't actually accidentally
start a conversation with him again as
soon as he's done talking I don't need
to be greedy like you go ahead and shoes
sagging all right so now we want to go
down and write once we're done this all
right let's go right
let's do it let's do it we get we got
this so we're gonna go right oh I
believe in us I believe in us
I believe in us I actually just copied
right and I'm just copying and pasting
it now and sending it in a text message
all right now we want to go up and press
a on which Pokemon should we select
Charmander squirtle or Bulbasaur well at
least we're gonna be able to fight
against Charmander so you know what it's
it's probably better because I owe a a
ai ai okay j-p-j Z okay cool really
creative nickname extremely creative
nickname and this fools gonna take
Charmander so now we have to now we have
to battle him so let's go down yeah just
like send down so we can go there and
what's our strategy gonna be for this
battle we're just gonna repeatedly
tackle should we do that
you want to use growl at all that you
want to I don't think I don't think
Bulbasaur has tailwhip but like I think
Charmander and Charmander and squirtle
do right well no squirtle has growl
Charmander has tailwhip right I don't
remember because I'm apparently not a
Pokemon master
yeah I think Charmander has tail whip
and Bulbasaur has growl so all right Jay
Z by W : semicolon
my strategy is gonna be just a spam a oh
no oh no oh we hit growl we're growling
at each other oh yeah we're gonna tackle
tackling now not a very strong tackle
probably oh no we're gonna if we can if
we lose to this Charmander what does
that say about the JavaScript community
if we can't stick together to beat this
Charmander oh you scratching us okay I
think I believe in us I think we got
this you know what I should have done to
give us a little head start I should
have grabbed that potion from sag News
PC at the beginning of the game before
like and then saved after that but that
would have been cheating we don't need
to do that we can we can do this
ourselves as long as we just span a and
get lucky I think we're gonna win we got
to press it like up but once not like oh
no no no well at least the Charmander is
gonna be really weak we're just growling
at each other this is like a
intimidation match right here oh yeah
only to damage you know what I still
have faith in us I think we can uh
alright we hit tackle we attack alai
think we're oh no critical hit uh-oh
that ain't good okay alright alright
he's doing nothing right now so that's
good uh-oh I think we can do it though
we're at least making a weaker I'm not
I'm not all alright we're tackling again
Charmander is growling at us getting
weaker as time goes by but so is trying
matter oh man this is gonna be a Oh No
all right we're doing one damage to each
other now growl can't make him any
weaker because he's only gonna do one
damage No
Oh No all right nothing happened all
right all right we gotta girl if if
nobody ever presses up or down again
then I think we got this I think we can
win oh no you know I still I still
believe in us you know we just we get a
critical hit we can make this happen we
can win it's still possible it's still
possible
Oh No okay all right you know I'm never
gonna I'm not gonna give up on us I'm
not gonna give up that is unfortunate
that we missed and he's still growling
okay come on critical hit No
all right No
well well we lost we guess we're the
fools now man
well whoever shouted Charmander earlier
should be pretty happy right now because
at least you know deep down in your
heart that Charmander was the right
choice that's my favorite line in the
game Gramps smell you later but yeah I
mean I guess we lost that first battle
but I have faith that you know we can we
can grow as pokemon trainers we can come
together as a community and learn you
know because going to conferences is all
about learning and improving and stuff
you know so we're gonna become better
pokemon trainers yet just you wait and
see with that said I think that's about
all the time I have for you now my name
is Sam Agnew I'm a developer evangelist
at Twilio I'll be around at the karaoke
and the pool party later so come find me
if you want to talk about Pokemon or
JavaScript or anything I'll catch you
later have a good rest of j/s comp
[Music]
you